so Reggie we're here at e3 2015 Nintendo
once again put together a fun
imaginative Nintendo Direct presentation
how do you feel that it when I I know
that you don't have that same feedback
from the crowd that the other guys get
because they're in a big stage so how
and how do you gauge how well it went is
it social media it really is it's
real-time social media it's seeing what
people comment on what they like what
they don't like obviously mr. wada mr.
Miyamoto myself in public forum was very
exciting for folks and it was it was a
wonderful concept was a great concept
and it actually ties back to some of the
things that mr. Miyamoto has said
historically that growing up he played
with puppets made puppets and that led
to a lot of the imaginary things that
he's gone on and done since and you know
as I look at the the digital event
certainly starfox is shown really well
and it continues to show well when I did
go out on the floor that there's a
massive line of people wanting to play
that super mario maker has been a
highlight for us and as soon as we saw
the reaction in the Nintendo World
Championships we knew that that game
would show it seemed extremely well
Yoshi's woolly world is another fan
favorite so when we put these together
we do have a strong sense for what are
the games that are going to do
exceptionally well you know we also
learn along the way you know what things
maybe aren't as clear as we want them to
be and that's where we put added focus
during the show and so example Metroid
Prime Federation force we knew it was a
tough concept right it's it's a game
taking place in the metroid prime
environment but there's no samus and the
gameplay is different so how do we
communicate that and we tried hard to do
that in the digital event were hearing
that maybe then it wasn't as clearly
communicated and so we're spending time
on it during treehouse live and again
that's one of the benefits that we have
in just the overall approach that we
take for a three it's just not a press
conference and then come play our games
we look for a range of opportunities to
help people understand what's magical
about our content because we know once
we get a controller in your hands you're
going to have a wonderful experience and
so we're doing that now and what's
interesting is that I'm now hearing that
the reaction to blast ball has been
quite fabulous so things are good and
you guys I think more than a new the
other companies have a direct line with
your fans I mean who else could put
together a world championship right
before an event like III how did the
Nintendo World Championships go what was
the sentiment after that sentiment
expand taxing whenever we do something
that's brand new we'll set up
expectations and then we'll measure our
performance against those expectations
so we had targets for simultaneous views
we had targets for the VOD views
immediately after and those targets were
blown away with our actual performance
as of last night we had about 2.5
million VOD views and that's before we
my words clean up the video because
right now there was a long lead on it
we're doing some things and we did
overnight to tighten that up but based
on what I've seen so far that video is
going to have probably by the time we're
done here at e3 3 3.5 mil use so it's
gonna be pretty massive so it sounds
like it was a huge success is that
something you you think you would
revisit or is it kind of a one-off
special event for the 30th anniversary
you know the wonderful thing about our
approach is that for us III is not
cookie cutter right we don't say this is
going to be the formula let's lock it in
we're going to do that for the next five
years we really try and think through
what's going to be best what's going to
be most effective in communicating the
appeal
of the games and then we actually from
there this year with the anniversary of
Super Mario with Mario maker as a key
game plus the launch we just had a
splatoon which we believe could be a
great competitive game it made sense for
us to bring back the world championships
certainly the feedback by the fans has
been phenomenal so it's going to make us
consider you know how we maybe do this
on a much more frequent basis then then
you know every 25 years but you know for
us it is it is about doing something
that's fun for the fan and in looking at
the conference as a whole I think there
was a great focus with with your
presentation on what people can look
forward to this year uh but i think mr.
Miyamoto had said that you guys did
actually have some footage of zelda for
wii u that was really phenomenal but you
decided not to bring it to the show how
for for something that you know fans
also really want to see much of that
decision so again our mentality is that
we want to showcase at e3 games that are
launching over the next six nine months
right that's our mentality now in
fairness we break our own rules all the
time but but generally speaking that's
our mentality we had just announced a
delay of zelda right that it would not
launch in 2015 and so we were concerned
that by showing wonderful footage of the
game it would lead to further
disappointment on behalf of the fans so
that was the judgment call that we made
there'll be plenty of opportunities for
us to showcase that game and certainly
for those of us like myself who've seen
the game and see how it's progressing
you know no fears that's going to be
wonderful but you know we believe that
this year we had a tremendous lined up
we had more than enough content to
showcase this year at e3 and so it was a
decision to you know let's not pour salt
on the wound so to speak
and in focus our next showing of Zelda
at a later day and the Wii U has just
had I think probably one of its best
years ever it's it's yes after kind of
maybe a rocky start in some ways it's
rebounded in and completely I guess for
you what is the state of the wii u now
especially going into the next part of
the year where we see all of these great
titles now the state of the weed was
quite strong and you said it well you
know the the Wii U has had a strong year
and if you look back to you know just
about a year ago to where we are today
yeah mario kart smash brothers splatoon
what a great one two three points and so
we know that in this business software
is what drives hardware and as long as
we focus to continually bring great new
software on that regular basis we're
going to continue to drive the install
base you know the the support we're
getting from third party continues to be
there the announcement we made with
skylanders and activision has been
incredibly well-received and so for us
it is about making the great content
launching you know great innovations
like amiibo and to continue driving that
forward and splatoon it seems like every
time that I play I've never had a I've
never had to wait long for a match it's
I'm easy it's easy to get into the
netcode seems really strong it's free
you know from my end as a player it
seems to be doing well I guess from your
end from Nintendo's and is it also doing
really well as a sports performing
exceptionally well you know on a global
basis the sell-through has been quite
strong as you highlight you know and it
tells you just how much people are
playing the fact that you get into
matches very quickly and our continuing
announcement of new modes new weapons is
going to continue to keep people engaged
so we're very pleased with the waist
mattoon is taken off going back to them
into the director at second and to all
the presentations you guys do like I
think it's always impressive house in
if they are how fun they are to watch
dude is that something that you ever
have any input into or miyamoto like
creatively or is that something you have
an outside team come in like say we have
a great idea we're going to do Muppets
this time no so we do it all internal
and we have some external support
whether it's in the digital event or you
know as we do various Nintendo directs
but the core activity is done internally
you know so you know an example when we
did the introduction for this year's e3
the announcement video of what was going
to be new and different you know we we
had a script but we made some things up
as we went along and one of the things
that we made up was the ending when I
fire bill right that was totally
unscripted it we adjust you know it was
fun and it was a thing to do so then as
we prepared for the mini direct we
thought it'd be fun to have bill small
right working his way back up and so it
really was you know that fluid and the
reaction was quite possible and it's
been really exciting to see how
Nintendo's transitioned into the this
figurine space that has been kind of
dominated by Skylanders Disney is
stepped in very well and Nintendo had
definitely is a very diverse mold I was
so surprised to see the animal crossing
characters come up I like as a huge
hundreds of hours in an animal crossing
family it makes me really happy to see
those head how are you guys feeling
about how a meebo are going we're
extremely pleased with amoeba and you
know the last numbers we announced were
back at the end of March at that point
on a global basis we'd sold through
about 10.5 million units about two-third
of that volume was coming out of the Noa
territories so we're extremely pleased
with our performance today now having
said that we also know that there's some
consumer frustration out there and so
we've made the commitment
that we're going to improve the flow of
product into the market and we've
delivered on that in the 30-day time
period for the most recent launch of new
amoeba during that 30-day time period we
sold through about a million units so I
mean you can't do that without putting
more product into the marketplace and
driving real improvements in your supply
chain so the performance has been good
and now we're looking forward to
different form factors whether it's the
yarn Yoshi amiibo whether it's the cards
for Animal Crossing and we're going to
continue to innovate in this space
because for us it's all about you know
the magic that happens when you when you
do something to either that gamecube
excuse me thank you wow I think I still
have the Nintendo World Championships on
my mind it's what happens when you put
the the meebo figure or the the card for
animal crossing against that our gamepad
controller or against the face of the
new Nintendo 3ds that magic that happens
for us is what amiibo is all about so
we're going to continue to experiment
with the form factor and go from there
and I think bringing amoeba over to
Skylander superchargers is is a really
interesting like to a fun move but I bet
a lot of fans also wish that they had a
dedicated Nintendo experience for that
is that something that's off the table
because you're moving in the skyliners
or is that and when you say a dedicated
Nintendo experience what do you mean
well so something that would be like
Nathan Nintendo universe or Nintendo
Landers if you would like a toy box
where you could play with your own
amiibo right so I've got nothing to
announce today in that space but I'll
tell you you know the the treehouse team
myself we visit Japan very frequently
and all of us share our our wishes with
the development team of what we'd love
to see and it's it's not it's not saying
anything out of school to say that we've
can
indicated that we think there's a strong
opportunity for a dedicated amiibo
centric game where it's all about the
magic that happens with amiibo and so
I'm certain that the developers are
thinking about it and thinking about
what's the unique Nintendo spin that
would come in that type of gameplay and
looking at the games that we are getting
for the rest of this year it feels like
there is a strong focus on the core you
have that mario tennis serve the zelda
like these games that are catering to
fans gonna blade 0 what is going to be
key for the core anything you mentioned
next year is when maybe we'll be talking
about mobile and where nintendo will fit
that into their plans more where do you
see gamers going like nintendo gamers
how are they going to be evolving
through this year and into next year you
know for us gamers who enjoy our IP are
going to continue to experience them on
Wii U they're going to continue to
experience them on the 3ds they're going
to experience them in the future on
mobile devices and in the future on NX
the common thread in all of this is
going to be that we will be delivering
unique compelling differentiated
experiences that only Nintendo can do
leveraging its IP and constantly pushing
the envelope in terms of what's fun if
three years ago I would have come to you
and said you know what would be fun this
game where your meat character does
really wacky things with other me
characters you'd look at me like I had
three heads and yet Tomodachi life was
one of the big surprises last year and
you know we're going to continue to find
ways to innovate that's what we do oh
and one of the things that I thought was
a really great way to service fans was
the India nouncement for earthbound at
the World Championships I like for me
personally as it as a huge earthbound
fan is a big D Tuohy fan like that felt
giving giving us fans hope that the this
series is still something that's dear to
Nintendo as well
so as I think leading from that in lieu
is maybe a little bit of a surprise that
we didn't hear more about it at the
Nintendo Direct is that is there any
hints that you guys are still thinking
about earthbound is a serious we know
the the love that our fans have for that
franchise in that series and we thought
that making the announcement and making
it immediately available through the
eShop was a great way to service that
fan love in terms of where we go from
here again I've got nothing to announce
but you know the little skit we did at
last year's digital event where I'm
constantly being asked about mother 3 it
happens right it happens so so we know
the love is there and we'll see what
happens so why did you guys choose to go
with mother one to the original
earthbound you know really from our
standpoint there are so many consumers
who don't know the fundamental series
and we thought it would be best to kind
of bring them back to the beginning to
help them understand what it's all about
and why it's captivated people in such a
magnificent way okay um so not not as
much related to Nintendo but looking at
the industry as a whole I think we've
seen a lot of companies going into
virtual reality of course Nintendo has
had a large history with that Microsoft
with a hollow lens Sony with project
Morpheus but for you personally as you
know an insider in the development
agency where do you see virtual reality
what is it the virtuality virtual
reality needs to to take off to be
something look our industry loves to
focus on the shiny new thank you and
right now the shiny new thing is virtual
reality last year at e3 I was fortunate
enough to experience all of the various
executioner's I've continued to stay
close Nintendo is a company continues to
stay close with how this technology is
evolving
from a consumer standpoint it needs to
be fun and the experience needs to be
something that is a real wow experience
my only my own personal point of view is
that I also believe that our art content
is inherently social so i think in in
some way this has to be a social
experience as well when those
interconnect something that is
inherently fun and something that is
inherently sociable and shareable is I
think when this technology will take off
and I haven't had a chance to see what's
here but when those concepts connect
it'll be a movement well thanks so much
for taking time out and talk with me at
a very busy III absolutely happy to do
it thanks